frankie montos on the mound for the
athletics and i think we could all agree
that even though his record is six and
six
he's making his 14th start if frankie
didn't have any bad luck he wouldn't
have any at all right now if they're the
first 13. so maybe the
last 18 19 starts for frankie 20 who
knows how many he might have that he
could pitch like we know he can justin
upton leads it off for the angels
against montauk long ought to miss in a
fast ball away and that's the way our
ball game begins fastball spotted just
exactly where he wanted to run it gets a
swing and miss
and that'll bring up otani the swinging
a ground ball to the right side tony
kemp at second throws the first for the
out and that is that number two a little
bit of ohtani's own medicine because he
has a great splitter and that was the
montage splitter right there batter now
is iglesias swung out of foul held by
murphy the inning is over and for
frankie montage it's a one two three top
of the first andrew heaney on the mound
for the halos tonight making starting
assignment number 12 on the season
number 101 in his career he's been very
good having won his last three
assignments first batter up for the
oakland a's is mark hannah you go after
that one yes he did canada on that one
two
his uh victim on strikes there the
appeal to the first space umpire brian
knight so the batter now is chapman matt
takes low and chapman walks it comes
with one out in the bottom of the first
and olson's coming up fastballs to start
this one there's one that's hit a bunch
the other way but playable for upton for
route number two so we're two outs the
runner at first it'll be jed lowry
stepping up there's one that's lifted in
the air into right field shading the
eyes making the catch on that one is
taylor ward he has the sunglasses on as
well and that is how the inning will end
first batter up for the angels jared
walsh swung out of this those that buy
him a fastball 98.
walsh k is in montas really on his game
to begin the contest today three
strikeouts bring him up a late call by
moscoso strike three called on a
fastball 98. andrew heaty with a unique
look with those stirrups 17 pitches of
the first inning 11 were strikes got him
finally took care of him with the high
fastball that's a great spot where he
gets a lot of hitters to chase so that's
out number one and biscotti will be the
next batter he throws a fastball by him
elevated fastball struck him out any now
with three strikeouts already against
the first six batters that he speaks
runner at second with one god here comes
justin upton an opportunity here with a
runner in scoring position upton doesn't
waste any time that's out to right
center field and that's going to drop in
laguardia is being waved around to score
and the angels are the first to get on
the board tonight one thing that motos
has had difficulty with is the beginning
and now here comes ohtani swinging a
ground ball to first picked up by also
goes to second for one elvis back to
first in the dirt dug by olson in time
to get ohtani
3-6-3 and the ending is over
is it possible to make two gold gloves
plays
on one play i think we just saw it and
now tony kemp's got a lead off base hit
leading things off in the third marcano
will be the next batter this one's hit
well right center field
and nobody's gonna get it here comes
kemp he's gonna score and this game is
tied thanks to the rbi double mark and
now matt chapman there's a base hit left
field here comes
the good times continue to grow for the
a's third baseman and here come the
halos in the top of the fifth suzuki
with the blue laguerras with a harder
hit ball to right field now the angels
with one out and runners at first and
third and david fletcher is coming up
first ball swinging an rbi single into
center field and the angels have tied it
in the fifth three straight base hits
runners at first and third with two away
for shohei ohtani
with a split
[Applause]
iglesias is out that'll bring up jared
wang swung on line to right center and
sky ball coming up diving and he makes a
phenomenal catch
what a play by sky balls guy bolt acting
like he was shot out of the bottom of a
cumulonimbus
frankie montas is applauding from the
mound the bases are loaded and still
nobody out and seth brown coming up he
swung on a high fly ball in center field
olson scores and seth brown comes off
the bench gives the a's lead with a sac
fly is three two a's in the bottom of
the six now andrews will bet driven left
center up the alley nobody's there
that's gonna go to the wall lowry is
scored murphy's the third they're gonna
wave him and the a's take a five to two
lead frankie montauk stays out on the
mound for the seventh inning he needs a
huge shutdown ending here swing and a
miss the splitter and it's been a good
pitch for frankie matas that's his
seventh strikeout and he got him oh you
knew he was going to go with a splitter
it's been terrific tonight he strikes
out a pair he's retired eight in a row
so ohtani will bat with two out and the
base is empty one for eight in the
series oh oh show he got him got him
yeah
boy shohei teed off on that one you
could tell the moment he made contact
that's his 18th of the season and the
angels get a little bit closer now it's
a 5-3 oakland lead
lowry murphy and brown for the a's i
don't think he has a two-strike swing
lowry takes a big swing sends the ball
to center field lagarez leaps at the
wall and makes the catch
that's a gold glove fine catch by
lagares yeah gold glover back in 2014
with the mets and here's murphy's
strikeout five to left and walk five
free a's bottom of the eighth murphy
it's a deep left center field way back
lagarus will just turn and watch it fly
off the back wall
and the ears take a six to three lead
sky bolt now
[Music]
bolt rolls over
on the ground ball for fletcher that
gets sluggers out of any further trouble
he's laid 6-3 is vero potato zone trying
to save this so petite with a chance for
his second save of the year jared walsh
leads it off all for three struck out
twice then was robbed by bolt walsh
sends the ball out to center field that
ball is crushed and gone
one of them comes right back that's his
15th of the season and now the angels
trail by two here in the ninth inning
it's a 6-4 game the o2 delivery is swing
on bounce back a third backhand bobble
chapman picks it up rolls around throws
and he gets him
a no look whirling throw across the
diamond by chapman
after initially bobbling the ball in a
short hop preserving the sixth floor win
for the a's and for the first time since
2019
the a's are 15 games over 500.